NARRATOR: After surviving
a box jellyfish attack,
Dr. Yanagihara recovers at home.
The process is slow and painful.
After three days of brutal
agony and a week total,
there was no sustained relief.
My skin became
terribly inflamed all
along these different tracks.
Around my neck was
like rope burns.
I tried the topical steroids
and some other things.
And nothing worked.
Nothing worked.
I felt really curious
what happened to me.
Why did it hurt so bad?
What's the physiology of this?
What's the biochemistry
of the venom?
OK, you box jellyfish, you
brought the [inaudible] to me.
So now let me see
what makes this tick.
NARRATOR: Following
the incident,
Dr. Yanagihara
dedicates her life
to studying the creature
that nearly killed her,
making breakthrough
discoveries that
are crucial to public safety.
There's not many researchers
in this particular species.
Angel has done amazing work and
established that the jellyfish
moves with the lunar cycle.
Every month, 8 to 10
days after the full moon,
along Waikiki, these animals
would show up like clockwork,
exactly on the lunar calendar,
purposefully triggered
in the predawn hours to spawn.
NARRATOR: Her research not only
helps prevent jellyfish stings
but has led to the creation of
a topical treatment currently
used by the US Navy
special ops teams.
And for anyone who gets
stung by a jellyfish,
the remedy is simple.
The best first
aid is two steps.
First, flood the sting
site with vinegar
to inactivate these
little capsules so
that they can no longer fire.
And that keeps things
from getting worse.
Second, apply heat, 45 minutes
of 42 to 45 degrees Celsius,
which is basically
112 to 115 Fahrenheit
will irreversibly inhibit the
venom and change the course.
And now your body can repair
itself and you can recover.
One of the things that
concerns me is when folks want
to think of jellyfish
as nuisances or sinister
or they're out to get me.
I was crossing paths with
something that's been
going on for 600 million years.
Looking back on all
that I know now,
I understand that I was in the
wrong place at the wrong time.
When I entered the water,
I was entering their world.
And I crossed their path.
So that was not their
fault, but mine.
[music playing]